[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2 millions de vues sur youtube c'est
assez fugace on va dire que c'est un
petit peu prématuré pour parler de
célébrité c'est plutôt une une
satisfaction que de faire une chanson
d'autant plus une chanson contestataire
puisqu'il s'agit de ma chanson ça va
manu
ma chanson qui demande à notre président
de la république ou plus exactement à
notre mes prisons de la république de
dégager donc ça fait plaisir de voir que
je ne suis pas la seule à partager cette
colère inouïe contre ce mépris souverain
de notre sueur 1
[Musique]
en effet je viens d'avoir 45 ans il ya
un côté
d'obsolescence programmée de la femme à
partir de 45 ans tu en voilà on a
beaucoup entendu parler du tunnel des 50
les actrices de 50 ans qui ne trouvent
plus drôle en tant que chanteuse c'est
pareil ça fait les choux gras de
l'industrie cosmétique qui se fait des
milliards chaque jour en nous vendant à
des crèmes anti rides et en alimentant
ce enfants notre terreur de vieillir
donc moi je l'assumé en effet j'ai 45
ans je suis loin d'être parfaite
je suis pas du tour fait mais il se
trouve que que ce soit mérite que ce
soit ma peau que ce soit mes cicatrices
je suis là sommes aussi dans vécu une
expérience la somme de très belles
choses qui me sont arrivées la somme
peut bouger les choses qui me sont
arrivées mais que c'est ça qui en
l'occurrence appelle ma vie
[Musique]
c'est une stigmatisation si le club
parisien sion oui je suis engagé je m'en
moque sur scène je dis que je suis
engagé parce que je tolère pas
l'intolérence voyez que je préfère
marcher debout plutôt que marcher 1,6 il
se trouve que je suis une artiste
engagée politiquement bien sûr mais
aussi engagé dans ma vie ne serait ce
que le simple fait que de prendre un
stylo pour en faire une chanson c'est
déjà de l'engagement le 5 le fait que
des chanter une chanson d'amour c'est
déjà de langage ou où il se trouve qu'en
plus j'ai un côté haute est à terre mais
bon engagée si on veut me cataloguer
engagé bages la scion tout à fait parce
que c'est vrai mais je trouve que c'est
un petit peu réducteur haussier c'est
une bonne question que j'aimerais bien
d'ailleurs posé notre ministre
[Musique]
très nettement pour moi et d'ailleurs ça
ça n'engage que moi mais vous avez
raison c'est une chanteuse engagée
puisque ça n'engage que moi il est
urgent de revenir aux fondamentaux de la
solidarité
et c'est que comme ça qu'on va pouvoir
échapper à la morosité de cette époque
élitiste basée sur le fait de marcher
sur la tête des autres pour pouvoir soit
sortir la tête
mais en fait il ya pas tellement le
choix il ya pas tellement le choix dans
la mesure où le sexisme
ecotidien ya pas tellement choix quand
on voit le nombre de féminicide que nous
avons eu ne serait-ce qu'en france cette
année il ya pas tellement le choix quand
on voit la violence quotidienne que nous
avons et qui va dans dans tous les
milieux en scène ya pas de problème et
donc et dans tous les cas de figure j'ai
une fille de 17 ans qui s'est fait
traiter au combien de fois de plus tout
dans la rue parce qu'un type l'a
trouvée charmante et qu'elle ne
répondait pas c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que mon concert du 8 mars à la cigale se
déroule le jour les droits
internationaux de la femme et que dans
la journée il y aura un café féminisme
un féministe et un forum justement sur
le sexisme ordinaire sur l'infâme et les
droits de la femme la laïcité la femme
aujourd'hui dans notre société
[Musique]